James is in Atlanta Georgia
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show James
hey how's it going the day-day better
than I deserve sir what's up I want to
say thank you for answering the call and
so me my wife my wife just started a new
job I just started a new job so I went
to go get a second vehicle basically I
got the vehicle has high interest rates
it's going at nine dollars and 41 cents
a day and I was looking at that I just
made the first payment not too long ago
when I'm like hey you know I got to get
rid of this thing I just started
listening for you not coulomb type of
last two weeks and I don't need help
we're looking to you know start that
path of being debt-free and you know
trying to save for a home our son is
three so good yes sir how much you owe
on this car working fourteen thousand
four hundred and seventy six dollars and
what's your house what's your household
income seventy-five thousand dollars and
how much other debt do you guys have not
counting your house so you have one
other car which has thirteen thousand
left on it and she has student loans for
about fifteen thousand okay all right so
it's 45 thousand wouldn't have you come
be completely debt-free and out of 75 so
if you were to do that over two years
I'd be about twenty two thousand dollars
a year so roughly two thousand dollars a
month you get on a really really tight
budget and you have no life and no
vacations and you don't go out to eat
and you sell so much stuff the kid
thinks he's next
and your friends that are broke think
you've joined a cult
because you don't have a life and for
two years you get out of debt and it's
gonna be two grand a month on this debt
and you list your death smallest to
largest pay minimum payments on
everything but the little one and attack
the little one with a vengeance now it
sounds like that your car and her
are about the same price and the student
loans slightly about the same balance
the student loans slightly above now is
the interest rate on the new one
ridiculous yeah coming for the same oh
my goodness gracious yeah we're gonna
put it first because it's a tie with
your wife's car on the balance roughly
and you're gonna pay that thing off in
about seven months okay because you're
getting hammered yeah okay now what is
the lesson you learned about buying that
car man honestly some be honest days
I've been wanting to go ahead to just
sell it figure out a way to sell it in
take them right now we're on baby steps
one where where we're trying to Savin a
thousand dollars for emergency funds
I've been trying to sell it just to try
to buy a car cash and you know all right
if you want to do that that's okay that
that'd be fine it but you can get it
paid off real fast if you lean into it
and you you know you just stop your life
no life alright no life cut cut
everything out I mean food lights and
water and that's it
you know we're gonna pay off yeah that's
how you get out of debt it's complete
and total focused like that so I'm gonna
help you the lesson you should learn
from this is interest rates matter
number one so getting screwed at 24
percent is a dumb idea that will keep
you broke your whole life
number two you impulse the crud out of
this this was a complete impulse you
didn't even look at it until you got
home and then you'd like one to chew
your arm off when you looked at the bill
you were holding in your hand
because you felt so dumb okay and that's
what happens when we impulse something
big I've done it I've done the same
thing where I impulse something
particularly something big
you don't feel it when it's a stick of
gum you know if you impulse a biscuit
that's not a problem right but when you
impulse a freaking car it'll kill you
you have to go slow on big purchases
fast on small purchases and make good
wise decisions and of course pay cash
for everything from this point forward
so either sell it dump it and then work
your way through your debts no bomb then
pay cash for a better car or just work
and pay it off really really fast it'll
be the first thing
your debt snowball because it's
basically a time for the smallest